[Musique]
l'histoire retiendra de Benoît XVI le
premier pape de l'histoire qui aura
osé démissionner
les uns auront applaudis
plutôt progressiste plutôt en faveur
d'une évolution de l'Église catholique
on dit c'est très bien enfin un pape qui
ne se sentait plus la force à oser
démissionner les autres plutôt
conservateurs on regretté ce geste et
leur regretteront toujours en disant
mais pourquoi Benoît XVI a-t-il
démissionné pourquoi a-t-il finalement
laissé et lire derrière lui le pape
François qui était plutôt réformateur et
cela restera aussi comme une grande
énigme de ce pontificat en l'occurrence
il l'a fait cette démission et de la
poser en conscience profonde c'était un
homme d'une grande rigueur d'une grande
conscience intérieure une grande
droiture le jour où il s'est senti
incapable physiquement et mentalement et
psychologiquement d'assumer cette charge
absolument
énorme lourdes on se représente pas ce
que c'est que d'être finalement le
leader mondial d'une religion le jour où
il a senti qu'il ne pouvait plus en
conscience il a dit je
excusez-moi l'expression je peux plus
faire le job j'arrête et c'est tout
Benoît 16 finalement cet acte très
symbolique contradictoire entre sa
position plutôt sa haute stature de
théologie et le fait qu'il ouvrait une
brèche finalement dans la théologie dans
les logiques
cet acte courage qui a eu
apparemment un frêle mais finalement qui
était très courageux c'est ce contraste
voilà on peut prendre cet exemple de la
démission comme
le signe d'une personne éminemment
intelligente très consciencieuse faible
aussi reconnaissant ses limites et voilà
ce qui restera je pense de ce grand pape
[Musique]